[Applause]
about this just saw you meeting Katy
Perry's parents was that a long time
coming that was a long time coming I was
so excited to meet miss Perry and mr.
Perry it was so nice because they were
they're so sweet and they're actually
fans so I was just kind of blown away I
mean it has been non-stop Katy referring
to her mom up there saying her mom is
obsessed with you so did you feel that
obsession in person from Katy Perry's
mom no she was chill she's cool as
cucumber I mean you know I was just
super flattered that she even knew my
name so how does it feel to have
captivated all of the Perry women I mean
both of those ladies are very enraptured
by you
yeah just flattered and you know I mean
I just in all that I have you know Katy
Perry and her mother is my fan like I
just think that's the weirdest thing in
the world you took some risks tonight
how did it feel to do those performances
and to get the critiques that you got
you know shoot you know on those and
those were those songs kind of became my
own like through the week you spend like
every waking moment thinking about them
so they're they're my babies and I gave
them all I had and I'm proud of those
performances I mean it's got to be hard
for you because you feel like you set
the bar so high every week and you get
these words of praise but you got to
keep one up in yourself yeah it's a you
know you get down to the top five and
you're just like what in me Hades am I
gonna do next week you know it's but
luckily we don't just depend on
ourselves there's a wonderful team at
American Idol that helps us with our
voices and just making sure that we we
do up it you know so the next week
Carrie Underwood are we gonna see some
rock songs with a country spin what do
you want to learn from Carrie shoot
first off I want to pick her brain of
how she survived this and next I just I
do want to figure out how I can take her
song and make it my own with respect to
her because I love her catalog and I
want to pay dues to it and last question
for you you know being in the top five
and knowing that you guys are going on
this tour now it has to kind of feel
like whoa my career is really real this
is really happening
does that make you think about what you
want to do from here and really make you
see the future shoot I don't even know
how to think about tomorrow honestly I
don't but I do like I'm indebted to
America because they do believe in me
and they do think I could do this enough
to vote me into the top five so I mean
I'm gonna give her all she's got